Who's calling? Who is
this? Who is this?
Sorry, Sam. Um, Zachary. Zack. Which
Zack? Here. Zachary Adams. I just typed.
No, you're scaring me, brother. Go
ahead. What's your question? You're in
the dark, man. You're scaring me, bro.
Sorry. Okay. What is it, my brother? Ask
me.
Uh, my question is about the book of
Hebrews. I I somebody had told me that
like they thought that the author was
Paul and then now there's a consensus
that they don't know who it is. Yeah. So
modern consensus right modern consensus
right modern consensus.
Yeah. Historically let me answer the
question. So why is it in the canon?
Excellent question. If you look at it
historically there was some debates over
its canonicity because they didn't know
who the author was. But my brother,
understand that's an argument for the
integrity of the church. Why do I say
that? Hebrews is one of the most
powerful
apologetic in defense of the Trinity and
the essential duty of Christ. Because in
Hebrews 1, why are these people doing
this thing? Oh, Hebrews 1. In Hebrews 1,
Jesus is identified as the unchangeable,
immutable creator and sustainer of all
creation, Jehovah God in the flesh.
Hebrews 1:10-12. The very fact, the very
fact that some question its canonicity
tells you the church wasn't simply
blindly including books in the canon
that agreed with its theology because if
anything, if that was the prerequisite,
well, you had to obviously agree, but if
that was the only reason, they would
have included it. To them, it had to be
more than that. It had to be what they
called the principle aposttolicity.
meaning it had to have been composed
during the time of the apostles and
their companions when inspiration was
taking place. So the very fact some
question it tells you their integrity.
So why did it end up in the canon?
Because enough people believe it was
written by Paul. It was written by Paul
and most likely he used what they call
an emanuencis a secretary. And this has
been the belief of the church up until
modern times until the rise of
postenlightenment critical biblical
scholarship. Okay? So when you say
there's a consensus now, you're talking
about the consensus of 21st century
scholars due to the influence of liberal
critical scholarship because the early
church already already dealt with these
issues. Well, it's not name. How can it
be Paul? Well, he used the scribe. In
fact, there's a theory that says the
Greek of Hebrews is so close to the
Greek of Luke and Acts that most likely
Paul used Luke as his scribe secretary
to pen down the revelation. And once you
go with that route, there is no good
objection against Pauline authorship.
What good objection do you have? Paul
used Luke. You can't disprove that. So I
tend to agree with the voice of the
early church which was the tradition for
centuries that Paul wrote it using a
scribe and emanuensis and there are
reasons
why good reasons why to believe it's
Paul because even those who don't
believe it's Paul they believe it's
Pauline in its theology in other words
you see heavy emphasis of Pauline
thought or Pauline thought throughout
the letter and there's even a reference
to Timothy who is going to be released
from prison.
Hebrews 13:23. Let's quote that. Hebrews
13:23. See, Ariel, great minds think
alike, bro. Ariel, I was saying it and
you just wrote it. See, you think like
me, you must be great. Anyway, Hebrews
13:23. Let me read it for them. Know ye
that our brother Timothy is set at
liberty. He's been free. Of whom, if he
come shortly, I will see you. So be
careful of just accepting anything and
everything that comes from the pens or
the lips of modern scholars, even
evangelical scholars. Unfortunately,
even evangelical scholarship has been
influenced by liberal scholarship. And
I'm not saying everything in liberal,
you know, scholarship is bad because
that's a genetic fallacy. No, no. But a
lot of the arguments of liberal
scholarship, if push comes to shove, are
based on theories and assumptions, not
historical fact. And for some reason,
evangelical scholars want to embrace
these views even though they're not
based on facts, but assumptions and
theories almost because they want the
esteem of liberal academia. And you'll
find that even when it comes to textual
issues like Mark 16 9-20 or John 73 to
811.
My my response would be number one the
church already had an issue about why
it's anonymous and some people cast a
doubt on its canonicity but number two
enough people believe that there was
strong tradition connecting it with Paul
and that Paul may have used a scribe and
so they included in the canon. Number
three the very fact it was questioned
shows the integrity of the church. Why?
Because Hebrews is one of the most
powerful apologetic books, one of the
most beautifully indepth and profound
books expounding on the Old Testament
sacrificial system, Jesus's superiority
and Jesus being Jehovah in the flesh,
the son of the father, companion of the
spirit. So if anything wouldn't expect
to be any questions because the theology
is so solid but still that tells you it
wasn't sufficient to show that it's
theologically sound. It must have been
composed during the era in which the
apostles were there and their companions
with them receiving inspiration to give
us not just theological treatises but
inspired canonical writings.
That would be my response to be honest.
Thank you. That makes a lot of sense.
Thank you, Sam. So, brother, like I
said, don't just follow modern
scholarship. Weigh the arguments from
all sides and look into church history.
Let me encourage you. Go back and look
into church history. These spiritual
forebears of ours were not dummies. They
were brilliant, sophisticated,
philosophically trained men who already
wrestled with these issues. And they
were holy men who loved Jesus and were
were willing to die as martyrs. and many
of them did. To simply ignore them is a
travesty.
So, hope that answered your question.
You have another one. Thank No, I just
want to say that I just I'm just very
appreciative of all the stuff that
you've done. I've been listening to you
for years and it really changed the way
I think. I am an ex-Muslim and it just
really wow, you know, it ex-Muslim guys,
another man who found Jesus. Jesus shine
his face on you and seal you for his
glory forever. May you never return to
Islam or unbelief in Jesus name. Amen.
Thank you Sam. Man, you made my day.
Because you made my day, I'm gonna go
order me some pizza. I'm just kidding.
Thank you. Thank you, Sam. I'll go back
to this stream. Thank you. Bye. Good
questions, you guys. Man, good
questions. Hey Ariel, why do you think
like me,